sa fin marot fine plus c'est le titre
d'un article nécrologique publié après
la mort de ma soeur ma jolie soeur
m'attendre soeur et mon âme soeur ce
n'est plus ma poignardé le corps il
était si lourd ciblées sont que j'ai du
mal à le supporter
je savais bien et j'étais consciente
commençer n'existe plus elle est morte
elle n'est plus n'y avait en fait il
n'ya que ses affaires ses livres son
cartable beige ses lunettes rouges et sa
jolie petite rousse artisanale plein de
stylos et de quelques pièces de monnaie
que je garde toujours il y avait des
objets mais pas m ce n'est plus ma
déchiré plus que sa mort il était la
gifle qui m'a fait mal mais grâce à
laquelle je fus réveillé
nous sommes le 14 décembre 2006 je
célèbre mot mariage il semaines après
j'ai fait mes valises et j'ai pris mes
cadeaux que j'ai bien placé dans le
coffre de la voiture de mon cousin
car on devait déménager mon ex mari et
moi vers une autre ville là où il
exerçait sa profession de chimistes
principal
ma soeur sa fin le canton play avec
tristesse et laver les yeux rougis ces
relais et larmoyant
c'est normal c'était notre première
séparation et on a eu toutes les deux du
mal à le supporter surtout quand on a
vécu durant vingt ans comme des jumelles
nous portions les mêmes couleurs nous
avions les mêmes goûts nous avons et
gould nous avons également fréquenté la
même école primaire le même collège
le même lycée et la même faculté
quelques minutes avant notre départ mon
adorable le sort m'a serré fort contre
elle m'a embrassé au cou et m'a chuchoté
qui ne manque déjà
pour la calmer
j'ai proposé à ma mère qui nous
accompagne pour revenir le soir parce
qu'ils ne devaient pas rater les cours
du lendemain comme l'exigeait mamère
promesses dieu ma soeur m'a quittée
après m'avoir aidé à installer quelques
affaires elle a pris le chemin du retour
avec notre cousin mais elle n'est jamais
arrivée chez sa maman elle est morte
elle est morte suite à un accident de
circulation
pas tout de suite mais en pleine
opération à minuit à cause d'une
hémorragie interne que les médecins
n'ont pas pu stopper à temps elle est
morte à l'âge de 21 ans
quand je suis arrivé j'ai trouvé ma mère
à la porte de la marque
je lui ai dit je m'en souviens très bien
j'ai tué ma soeur ce n'est pas toi ma
chérie
c'est son destin m'a répondu ma maman
qui venait de perdre son aîné oui ce son
destin un destin
le destin le 21 décembre sa femme à
robin n'est plus à la morgue
j'ai revu ma soeur elle été relogés
souriant ce jaune comme un coin avec une
blessure une très profonde blessure à la
tête
je laisserai contre moi sa froideur m'a
angoissé
j'ai embrassé son franc s'est jouée sans
coup c'est même douce et ses pieds
froids
je sentais son odeur je lui ai demandé
de me pardonner
je ne trouve même pas les mots pour vous
décrire mon état je peux dire seulement
j'étais pitoyable oui j'étais pitoyable
faire et annecy j'étais enragé
j'ai hurlé au point de perdre conscience
mes deux pieds étaient presque paralysé
le moment de son enterrement était
horrible pour moi j'ai tout fait
japonisé je pouvais supporter de voir
son épitaphe ma soeur sa fin était
réduite en une inscription gravée sur sa
tendre aucune trace d'elle que des
souvenirs que des images que des objets
qui ne vaut rien
j'avais vu pas mal de temps avec le
sentiment de culpabilité
avant de réaliser que je me venge et de
ma propre personne que je me détruisait
c'est moi qui ait nourri ce sentiment
dévastateur de mon sens de mon âme et de
mes idées sombres mon deuil était très
profond il fallait quand même que j'ai
les yeux mais pas de la manière
je lave ou c'était si cruel c'était une
rude épreuve
elle m'en a pris le tout est éphémère
rien n'est éternel et que je pourrais
être fidèle à la mémoire de ma soeur
tout en agissant positivement
j'ai pris mon destin en main et j'ai
poursuivi
une publication sur facebook d'un groupe
de jeunes qui faisait un appel pour la
collecte de denrées alimentaires pour
une action humaine j'ai assisté à l'une
de leurs réunions dès lors on ne s'est
jamais séparé
c'est le groupe jeune abir sabine qui
est devenu plus tard l'association jet
navire sabine pour le développement
humain et ce après des années de travail
acharné d'engagement de militance de
bénévolat d'altruisme et d' expertise au
sein de l'association
je me suis enfin retrouvé je me suis
libéré de mes cauchemars je me suis
relevé parce que j'ai réussi à vaincre
mon pessimisme et mon malheur j'avais
besoin de guérir et jédir grâce à ce
travail associatif très fructueux pour
ma consolation et pour nos bénéficiaires
j'ai guéri grâce à mes amis
khalid fondateur et président de
l'association
omar trésorier medica membre actif de
meriem shea mais elle est bien d'autres
personnes qui m'ont tendu la main
les actions et les projets de
l'association qui revêtent un caractère
humain en cicatriser les blessures ils
sont tous marqués par des valeurs telles
que la solidarité la générosité
l'entr'aide le sentiment d'altruisme le
partage
la citoyenneté grâce à notre groupe très
homogène grâce aux dons et aux mécènes
nous avons réalisé plusieurs projets qui
sont devenus devise de l'association
jeunes à birsa bits pour le
développement humain et plus encore les
porteurs d'un grand projet socio
économique qui vise l'insertion
économique de cinq femmes dans une
situation de difficulté avec notre
partenaire notre mission
et d'aider à des personnes vulnérables
et souffrance chaque projet de
l'association à sa cible à sa
philosophie et sa vision stratégique
ce que nous avons réalisé est le fruit
de la ténacité de la volonté de la
patience de sagesse de tous les membres
de l'association
ce n'était pas et ce n'est toujours pas
facile de mener à bien de telles actions
cependant nous avons réussi à surmonter
tous les obstacles qui aurait pu nous
décourager et tu es en haut notre
passion pour le bénévolat
nous avons fait preuve de responsabilité
de courage et de détermination pour
arriver à nos fins je vous ai raconté
cette histoire
mon histoire est elle pas pour vous
rendre triste mais pour vous montrer
comment on peut sortir vainqueur d'une
rude épreuve
un malheur édition un truisme née de la
souffrance deux titres d'une expérience
humaine porteuse d'espoir que je viens
de partager avec vous la vie ce petit
mot la vie la vie nous amène des
épreuves plus ou moins difficiles
lorsqu'une épreuve survient sachez bien
qu'il y à toujours il leçon de vie on
dirait subir une souffrance sans en
tirer deux leçons de vie est une
terrible perte de temps et d'énergie car
alors on n'apprend rien on ne progresse
pas en souffrent inutilement soyez
optimiste et ne cédez pas au
découragement de la vie cherchent à
savoir la leçon de qui peut vous
enseigner une épreuve si vous y parvenez
vous sortirez grandi et triomphant
vous voyez cette fleur cette fleur
blanche
elle représente à mes yeux ma soeur sa
femme héroïne de mon histoire est relié
de ma vie est synonyme de pureté et de
limpidité
je vous l'offre avec tout le monde
l'amour
merci